voilà revenons à la libération des trois
derniers otages français au liban
l'histoire retiendra que cette
libération est intervenue le 4 mai 88 à
quelques jours seulement de l'élection
présidentielle l'histoire qui est
jalonnée de dates retiendra également
qu'il aura fallu plus de trois ans et
oui plus de trois ans pour libérer les
otages français
martine laroche joubert 22 mars 1985
marcel carton et marcel fontaine sont
enlevés à beyrouth-ouest par le jihad
islamique organisation intégriste pro
iranienne qui exigent l'arrêt du soutien
français à l'irak
le lendemain 22 mars c'est au tour de
gilles pérol directeur du centre
culturel de tripoli retenu par les farl
des chrétiens marxiste qui leur lâche 2
avril en échange semble-t-il de la
libération d'abdallah toujours
emprisonnés en france 22 mai sur la
route de l'aéroport enlèvement de jean
paul kauffmann et du chercheur michel
seurat les ravisseurs le djihad
islamique encore leurs exigences la
libération du commando chapour bakhtiar
près d'un an après le 5 mars 86 le
djihad islamique annonce l'exécution de
michel seurat d'après jean paul
kauffmann il serait mort d'un cancer
trois jours après la mort annoncée de
michel sera le 8 mars 86 l'équipe
d'antenne 2 est enlevée par le jr
l'organisation de la justice
révolutionnaire de mouvance iranienne
qui dénonce l'ensemble de la politique
française au proche orient le 20 juin
philippe rochot et jan janssen sont
libérés le 24 décembre c'est au tour
d'oreille cornea tandis que jean louis
normandin restent emprisonnés la même
année 86 deux autres français sont
libérés
camille son tag 84 ans et marcel
khoudary mais le 13 janvier 87
l'histoire recommence
roger auque journaliste est enlevée il
sera libéré le 27 novembre 87 par le jr
en même temps que jean louis normandin
d'antenne 2 il n'y a plus aujourd'hui
d'otages français aux mains
d'extrémistes libanais
oui mais